the all-new ibm z16 ibm cloud pack for
watson ai ops version 3.3 and the g2
spring reports all on this episode of
ibm tech now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
ibm technology
jumping right in we've got a huge
announcement this week with the release
of ibm z16 the next generation system
that will bring real-time ai for
transaction processing at scale
in the interest of time i'm only going
to cover two main features of ibm z16
the real-time ai and it being the
industry's first quantum save system
z16 brings ai inferencing capabilities
via the ibm telum processor an industry
first integrated on-chip ai accelerator
what does this mean for you and your
organization well for example for the
first time banks can analyze for fraud
during transactions on a massive scale
because ibm z16 can process 300 billion
inference requests per day with just one
millisecond of latency
similarly for consumers this could mean
reducing the time and energy required to
handle fraudulent transactions on your
credit card
as for the security aspect it's critical
to protect against today's threat and
posture against cyber criminals who may
be stealing data now for decryption
later
ibm z16 takes cyber resiliency further
by protecting your data against future
threats that could evolve with advances
in quantum computing
as the industry's first quantum save
system ibm z16 is underpinned by
lattice-based cryptography an approach
for constructing security primitives
that help protect data and systems
against current and future threats
to learn all about the details of this
exciting new release check out the blog
and press release i have linked below
next up i want to talk a bit about
version 3.3 of ibm cloud pack for watson
ai ops
version 3.3 helps bring proactive
incident management to it teams
silencing noise around alerts and
reducing time spent remediating false
positive incidents
in particular the story viewer brings
proactive incident resolution to the
forefront provides an alerts view and
when a deviation from the metrics
baseline occurs the side panel shows
metric anomaly details that highlight
the trend over time
when an incident occurs the story view
will show lots of context surrounding it
so you don't have to dig through events
in an event viewer
instead you'll see a holistic view of
the probable root cause the topology
showing that probable cause and
recommended automations that can help
resolve the story
in this way cloud pack for watson ai ops
version 3.3 delivers real-time insights
with business context empowering your
teams to make informed decisions faster
to learn more hit the link below
to wrap things up this week i want to
shine a light on how ibm was recognized
in the 2022 g2 spring reports
the g2 spring reports rank the world's
best software companies and offerings
based on authentic timely reviews from
real users
and ibm offerings were featured in
nearly 800 g2 reports earning over 150
different leadership awards across
various categories
this includes being ranked number one
overall in 34 reports being ranked in
the top three in 108 reports
positive feedback from customers and
awards like these are evidence of our
clear strategy to lead in the era of
hybrid cloud and ai and we are grateful
to everyone who submitted a review to
see a full rundown of reports and awards
check out the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in tech now